hey youtubers is Charlie so Walking Dead
is back in just four weeks so to get
everyone pumped up and ready I'm going
to be doing a series of countdown videos
so this one is going to be for Rick but
feel free to leave me suggestions on
which characters or big things you want
to talk about next they're also getting
ready to release season 4 on Netflix
really soon so if you're not cut up you
should have a pretty easy time finding
episodes for free or near free if you do
have access to AMC they usually do a
marathon in the week leading up to the
premiere and hello to any of you people
if you're just finding me for the first
time I'm going to be doing weekly
Walking Dead videos for season 5 I'll
even be doing a weekly giveaway that'll
explain at the end of the video but all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so since we're talking about Rick
just to get things started let's take a
look back real quick I know he got a lot
of hate for being farmer Rick last
season and what went down at the prison
and all that chaos in the aftermath that
Rick is dead though long live farmer
Rick season 5 is the start of like a new
totally badass Rick so here are my top 5
most badass Rick moments from the series
so far careful for spoilers from
everything through season 4 it's all
wait just a sec ok everybody ready here
we go number 5 Rick kills Shane bonus
points for Karl killing Walker Shane in
rapid succession I do love that they
give bigger characters bigger deaths and
Shane was kind of like the Rick while
Rick was away although once Rick came
back he kind of started the slow descent
into madness this wasn't like a passion
killing though this was Rick killing one
of his friends it was a family affair
you know they had this really weird
messed-up family thing going on with two
dads and one mom it's one of the better
examples of Rick finding it in himself
to kill one of his former admittedly
best friends and not getting too crazy
over it afterwards
he has this amazing ability to
compartmentalize this was all happening
in the events leading up to the season 2
finale and by this time in the series
Shane had really turned into a douchebag
so I was happy to see him go I mean it
wasn't a sad killing
although do you remember back during the
second half a season four when Rick and
Carl break into that house Karl breaks
down and throws Shane in Rick's face
this is the behind the scenes Chandler
Riggs and Andrew Lincoln we're trying to
think of the most messed up thing for
Carl to throw in Rick's face and they
came up with Shane but number 4 Rick
kills Dave and Tony during season two
this was from episode 9 the mid-season
premiere it's a classic example of quick
temper Rick shooting first asking
questions later he and Hershel were at
Hatton's bar talking about Herschel's
dead wife being guilty about how he led
Maggie and Beth on about her condition
cut two random appearance from Michael
raymond-james from Terriers that was
actually pretty cool guest appearance
and Tony who are part of a larger group
of nomads they press Rick and Hershel
about the location of the farm so they
can bring the rest of their big group of
nomads in push comes to shove and Rick
just ain't having any of it so I
finished Dave off with a headshot it was
really quick but it takes three bullets
to take Tony down just because he's so
massive and because the first two were
in his chest I feel like every time the
show does a bar scene though something
terrible happens so anytime they visit a
new one I've always thought that it's
like the director reminding us visually
this is like the opposite of cheers you
will never be glad you came to any bar
in walking dead that's not to say that
drinking is bad you know go ahead and
have your drink just make sure you don't
do it in a creepy bar but moving up to
three Ric hacks off Herschel's leg this
was from the season three premiere that
Lake totally did not go quickly but it
was this really messy really awesome
thing at the same time Hershel obviously
makes the mistake of assuming a body
lying on the ground is completely dead
it reanimates bites him Rick performs
surgery right there on the spot
so the hack job is like something right
out of a be horror movie and it looks
like it was just as much fun for the
props people to set it up as it was for
us to watch it go down on screen people
that work on horror movies and do things
like that you know really gory special
effects actually do really enjoy their
jobs it's a lot of fun but after
everything's said and done they look up
from the mess and see a new group of
survivors walk up with like the biggest
WTF faces you've ever seen like what the
hell just happened in here so I think a
lot of people's complaints about season
4 in the pacing had to do with the fact
that you know they were still at the
prison but the episodes just did not
have the kind of pacing or energy or
intensity the episodes like this had
like seed the season 3 opener it's
always interesting to hear Scott Gimple
and the other cast members talk about
the changes to the tone of the show from
half season to half season like
thematically every eight episodes
they're pretty open about the fact that
they completely change what the show is
and like I've been saying in a lot of
videos the first half of season five is
basically going to be like one giant
explosion but number two
Rick clears the prison like it is a
video game this is also from that same
first episode in season 3 the survivors
had the task of clearing the prison so
that they could live there and it just
turns into this video game killing spree
like unlimited ammo non-stop craziness
Rick is basically chopping meat up in a
barrel this is really fun thing where a
lot of TV shows will mirror things from
the past like if they did something in
the first episode of one season they
might try to do something similar in the
first episode of another season in a
visual way just as an homage so I'm
really hoping that they just like hack
their way out of terminus as an homage
to the way they hack their way into the
prison you know obviously they won't be
clearing terminus so that they can live
there they'll be clearing it so that
they can escape but I'll say some of the
more fun takedowns in that season 3
opener when they're clearing the prison
is when they find those armored guards
if you remember Glenn actually ended up
using some of that armor to escape the
prison in the second half of season 4
but finally my number 1 totally badass
Rick moment biting out Joe's neck this
is the best example of Rick gone crazy
like I don't give a crap about anything
but making this threat in front of me go
away it was also one of the crazier
moments from the comic books usually the
show is like a complete divergence from
the comic book story but every once in a
while they'll pick like a really big WTF
scene to do there's also this big
transformation for Rick you know he was
just shaking off whatever funk had been
on him for all of season 4 and roared
back to life all over Joe's neck Andrew
Lincoln actually explained how they shot
the scene it basically involved a lot of
bra meet really early in the morning he
said that whenever they were setting up
Greg Nicotero came up to him and said
chicken or fish and Andrew Lincoln took
a sec till it was explained that the
chunk of neck that he be biting out of
Joe would be uncooked meat so he chose
chicken I guess that means raw chicken
tastes better than raw fish the whole
thing was completely surreal and one of
the best scenes from season four it was
just a shame that we had to wait all
season to get to that kind of action
even crazier part to all that though is
the next morning when they're all
sitting there in the mess of claimers of
their dead bodies and Rick just looks
like he's totally over it like he's like
yeah
no big deal just compartmentalized let's
move on I know I've been calling him
machine gun Rick in my season 5 bonus
videos so far but really we should just
call him crazy Rick like he's going to
be crazy Rick and season
five so for anyone who didn't like
season four as much I feel like your
prayers have been answered with this
first half of season five
I've also I've been following the
production behind the scenes for the
second half so I'll have to explain just
a little bit so you can totally turn the
volume down until this tag goes away if
you don't want to know anything about
the second half of season 5 ok everybody
ready here we go so basically it looks
like the group is just going to be on
the run for the duration of the second
half of the season based on the timing
when they're shooting episodes that
still kind of looks like she's stuck in
that creepy Hospital just based on the
amount of time they spent shooting there
so she'll at least be there halfway
through the season
okay so spoilers over so just talking
more about Rick in season 5 I don't want
to use the term hunter just because
that's a very specific group from the
comics but Rick is a lot like a predator
running point for the survivors at least
in the first half of the season
it's still a little unclear what's gonna
be going on in the second half but we
can talk about that as the episodes
start I can't show it here in this video
but during Comic Con they aired this gag
reel of Andrew Lincoln warming up for
scenes by screaming obscenities running
around punching stuff basically like he
was getting ready for a boxing match
that's the kind of Rick that I'm really
excited to see this year just a
hurricane of claws and teeth okay so big
question for you guys what is your
absolute favorite badass Rick Grimes
moment from anywhere in the series if
you've read the comics and you want to
talk about something from that just
please use spoiler tags in the comments
and here's the details on the giveaway
my bonus videos for the next couple of
weeks as well as what's going to be
going on once episodes get here the
premiere is on Sunday October 12th so
for the next three weeks I'll be doing
bonus countdown videos just to help
everyone get pumped up and get ready
then when we get to the actual weekend
of the premiere I might do just a little
bit extra my Saturday Doctor Who videos
kind of bump into Sunday a little bit
sunday is basically going to be
dedicated to Walking Dead though the
giveaway is basically gonna be the exact
same type of giveaway I did during my
season 4 videos all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce the
winner for this week's giveaway in my
Q&A tomorrow I am posting a Q&A for this
video I'll continue to remind people
about the giveaway but if you have
questions feel free to ask them there is
also a bunch of other stuff that's
starting next week so I encourage you to
all check it out as I post videos so all
the new Marvel the DC TV shows are
coming so hopefully you guys will check
them out I think you'll really enjoy
them but right now you can click here to
get my breakdown
season 5 trailer and you can click here
to learn all about what's going on with
the Walking Dead spinoff thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives